not every former cast member of Night
Court has returned for the rebooted
series from untimely deaths to actors
who gave up Showbiz altogether here's
what happened to the show's original
cast in a 1989 interview on NPR Harry
Anderson was blunt about starting his
career as a con man magician running
confident Street tricks to fool marks
out of their cash after getting his jaw
broken by an angry Mark Anderson
transformed his street act into a
legitimate stage show he was discovered
by Kenny Rogers manager who booked him
as Roger's opening act which led to
early roles on Saturday Night Live and
cheers among others and eventually his
signature role as judge Harry Stone on
Night Court what the hell was that while
he was still Doling out mostly
snack-sized doses of Justice on Night
Court Anderson was making sure he would
be no one hit wonder he followed up
night court with a successful four-year
stint as humor columnist Dave Berry on
cbs's Dave's World along with numerous
other gigs over the years in 2002 he
opened his own magic shop in New Orleans
speed and Archer Curiosities By
Appointment three years later he cut the
ribbon on his nightclub Oswald's
Speakeasy in New Orleans French Quarter
unfortunately Harry Anderson left us far
too early in 2018 Anderson passed away
in his sleep the cause of death was a
stroke at 65 Complicated by influenza
and heart disease
John Larroquette memorably filled in the
role of prosecutor on Night Court as Dan
Fielding despite often being cruel Dan
occasionally reveals surprising depth
such as in season 3's wheels of Justice
part 2 when he makes an impassioned
argument to Judge Stone to not quit his
job professionally larocet hasn't slowed
down for a second since Night Court
after that show banged its final gavel
laroquet followed it up with the
acclaimed the John larroquet show which
lasted three seasons in a small
recurring role larocet was nominated for
a total of three Emmy Awards winning two
of them for his portrayal of the
brilliant murderer Joey Herrick on the
practice along with his film work he's
landed far too many regular recurring
and one-off rules to list including Carl
sack on the dramedy Boston Legal Jenkins
on the fantasy Adventure series The
Librarians and Gavin Firth on cbs's the
good fight and laroquette isn't done
with Dan Fielding in late 2020 variety
reported the actor would return to the
role for a night court Revival news that
came to fruition when the sequel series
premiered in early 2020 E3 if you want
to make sure everyone in your courtroom
behaves bull is a pretty good guy to
have around Richard mull plays the
bailiff who at six feet eight inches
Towers over just about everyone else in
the courtroom and whose shaved head
helps to cut an intimidating figure his
ability to easily lift none other than
Lou Ferrigno off the ground in season
2's battling bailiff impresses a
wrestling promoter enough to offer him a
job but despite how he looks Bull's just
a big softy since leaving Night Court
behind Maul's made some memorable
appearances in films and television over
the years he plays a ghost in the horror
parody Scary Movie 2 the mystical
drifter in the Nickelodeon series 100
Deeds for Eddie mcdowd and the TV super
villain dementor in the 1996 Christmas
comedy jingle all the way I'm gonna take
your Halls Bob of all of Nightcore's
characters perhaps the most consistently
level-headed is the court clerk Mack
played by Charles Robinson Mack can
often be found behind the bench caring
for a tall stack of file folders ready
to hand off the next case to to Judge
Stone once Nightcore was over Robinson
hit the ground running while he gathered
plenty of film credits most of his work
comes from television after Love and War
Star John Hancock passed away in 1992
Robinson stepped in as a new regular on
the sitcom and was there until the
series penultimate episode in 1995. he
also played Bud Harper on the show that
made Tim Allen's career Home Improvement
Robinson never slowed down one of his
later credits is for the timely 2020
freeform miniseries Love in the Time of
Corona about different people trying to
make new connections and keep current
ones alive in an age of social
distancing in 2021 Charles Robinson
passed away at the age of 75 from
Cardiac Arrest as a result of a
prolonged battle with cancer
Marky post was something of a late Comer
to night court but it's tough to imagine
it without her while she makes a guest
appearance in the show's second season
as public defender Christine Sullivan
she didn't become a regular until the
third season premiere the naive and
pure-hearted Sullivan is there for the
rest of the series circling Judge Stone
as a love interest and dodging Dan
fielding's advances after night court
post landed the role of liberal news
reporter Georgie Anne Lottie on the
sitcom hearts of fire starring opposite
John Ritter as the conservative John
Hartman in the years that followed she'd
work regularly on the big and small
screens including appearing as Cameron
Diaz's mom in one of the more painfully
memorable scenes of the 1998 comedy
There's Something About Mary post was
diagnosed with cancer in October 2017
and remained professionally active while
undergoing treatment sadly she died from
the disease in August of 2021 at the age
of 70. when Night Court begins Richard
Mull's bull Shannon isn't the only
bailiff keeping things in order he's
joined by the chain smoking and
wisecracking Selma hacker played by
Selma diamond with the difference in
their heights providing a wonderful
contrast Selma and bull have great
comedic chemistry and Selma acts as a
mother figure to the younger Bowl sadly
Diamond died of lung cancer at the age
of 64 two seasons into night Court's run
Diamond was succeeded by Florence Halep
as bailiff Florence Kleiner like Selma
Florence provides the mother figure that
both so desperately needs in a
devastatingly tragic coincidence halop
like diamond died of lung cancer before
the end of Nightcore's third season she
was 63 years old
some fans were concerned about Marsha
Warfield when she signed on to play the
tough bailiff Roz Russell for Night
Court The Tragically similar deaths of
her predecessors had some wondering if
the show was cursed Warfield told people
in 1988 that she was concerned but not
for her physical safety she explained to
the outlet when I first went on the show
I was a bundle of nerves and I'm still a
bundle of nerves I'm scared they're
going to find out I don't know what I'm
doing considering her humorous
performance as the no-nonsense Roz she
clearly knew more than she thought she
did after the end of Night Court
Warfield did a lot of one-off
appearances in series like the John
Larroquette show and mad about you her
longest running post tonight Court role
was on the NBC sitcom empty nest as
physician Maxine Douglas warfield's
acting credits and in 1999 but she
hasn't been sitting on her hands
Warfield has continued to make audiences
laugh but on the stage as a stand-up
comic rather than on the screen
for most of Night Court the court
stenographers don't have much time in
the spotlight that changes in the final
two seasons with the introduction of the
ditzy stenographer Lisette played by
Jolene Lutz the naive and clueless
Lisette is a friend of bull Shannon Lutz
has continued to act over the years
though her credits are a little sporadic
she had a recurring role in the general
hospital spin-off Port Charles and
enjoyed memorable one-offs on series
like Lois and Clark and Pushing Daisies
at the same time Lutz has been pursuing
another passion zoology in a 2013 radio
interview let's described how she came
to volunteer for the Los Angeles Zoo and
eventually created its Sex and the City
Zoo fundraisers in which she educates
the public about the mating habits of
animals every good schemer needs a loyal
Lackey and for the mischievous
prosecutor Dan Fielding that Lackey is
the unhoused Phil Sanders played by
William Ute Phil eventually dies but
Fielding isn't left without a henchman
Phil's wealthy identical twin brother
will also played by Ute shows up to pick
up his dead brother slack in night
Court's final season both before and
after his time with Night Court Ute had
mainly one shot and recurring
appearances on different TV shows with
one major exception while sitcom fans
may know utay best as the twin brothers
doing fielding's Dirty Work followers of
daytime drama are much more familiar
with the actor in another longer running
role since 1985 except for some notably
long breaks from the show Ute has played
Dr Wilhelm Rolfe in numerous episodes of
NBC's popular soap opera Days of Our
Lives
while you may know him as the Android
data from Star Trek the Next Generation
before he was serving aboard the
Enterprise Brent Spiner played one of
the most hilarious recurring characters
on Night Court starting with the season
3's two-parter wheels of Justice Spiner
played Bob Wheeler a slow-talking Yokel
whose family keeps being dragged in
front of Judge Stone with Incredible
Tales of disaster his Tale in his first
appearance is so dark and unbelievable
it stuns Judge Stone into
uncharacteristic silence the judge then
calls recess without any more outlandish
Tales to tell on night courts finer
found his career-defining role of data
on the Next Generation he also landed
memorable roles like The Eccentric Area
51 doctor in the Independence Day films
LAPD Captain Ned vanderhoff in the
series Penny Dreadful City of Angels and
the Mysterious preacher Sydney in
Outcast before Marky post was added as
the regular public defender Christine
Sullivan in season three of Nightcore to
Billy Young played by Alan Foley was the
attorney clashing with Dan Fielding in
the show's second season passionate
about defending her clients and having a
good sense of humor that made for great
chemistry with Judge Stone Billy was the
judge's good friend and love interest
that is until Foley left the show behind
to pursue other opportunities in the
worlds of acting and music Foley's
biggest claim to fame has nothing to do
with night court or any other acting
role Foley is the female half of the
duet from Meatloaf's 1977 hit single
Paradise by the Dashboard Light and her
vocals have also appeared on albums by
acts like Blue Oyster Cult and punk rock
Legends The Clash Foley has released
solo albums as well including 2013's
about time Foley doesn't seem to want to
be tied down to any one thing giving
equal time to music and acting as such
her acting credits are more sporadic
since leaving Night Court she's landed
roles in major Motion Pictures like the
1987 Thriller Fatal Attraction and
1988's cocktail she's also appeared in
recurring roles for the daytime Drama
All My Children in the second season
episode take my wife please Mac is
reunited with Quan Leduc played by
Denise kumagai kuanlei is a Vietnamese
woman whose family nursed Mac back to
health when he was injured during the
Vietnam war Mack agrees to marry Quan Le
who is in America on a temporary Visa so
she won't be sent back to Vietnam while
their Union is initially a green card
marriage Quan lay harbored feelings for
Mac for years and eventually Mack
realizes he shares those feelings
kumagai's acting credits end in 2006
with her recurring role of Aunt June on
the popular dramedy Gilmore Girls since
then kumagai has continued to work on
something she helped to create even
before she appeared on Night Court in
1981 kumagai co-founded the cold tofu
improv team a Los angeles-based improv
and comedy troupe
[Music]
foreign